The Joe Rogan experience.
Well, the problem is it
doesn't, it stifles innovation.
You, you become really pedantic
and good at following instructions,
but you're not going to be
very innovative. You'll be
really technically good,
but you also want to be naughty and you
wind up sacrifice shit like Yo yo Ma was,
he would try, he tried a
bunch of different instruments
until he finally said,
I'm going to play this. Yeah, you want to
be naughty. You want to fight it. Yeah.
You want to fight mommy?
You want and you probably have some
Weird Mommy Porn bookmarks, Huh?
Ah Huh. There's amazing amounts of
stepmom porn. Really. It's all step-mom's.
Well pornhub like mom, your father's
going to be so mad at you go,
well mom,
mom or a derivative of mom is,
I think the second most
typed in word in a porn hub.
Giant sir.
[inaudible] Ted something saw
something to do with young but,
but mom is nothing.
Granny porn is huge in Kenya and the UK.
Do you know why they think because you're
raised by an older lady or an older
man, your headmaster, they're
in a position of authority.
And as you're coming to,
well as you're coming to
and you're formulating your
point of view of the world
and making sense [inaudible] you tend
to sexualize whatever's in front of you.
I guess that makes sense.
You in print so,
so gilts and you know that's Kinda hot.
Grandma's.
I'd like to fuck what
kind of world we live in.
My friend's wife catches her
watching grandma porn. Gray, gray,
old men, Bang and gals. She's into that.
She said the old dude's, she's getting
old guys like real old like body.
Your body looks like warm cheese. Whoa.
You understand? Why would they like that?
I don't.
It's who the fuck knows.
That is a weird thing though that you
hear that some women like really old guys.
You don't hear that from women or from
men rather. Yeah. What does it say?
The world's news photos and this is a
bet she was hot as fuck back in the 80s
100% yeah. What are you going
to do? Listen man. Old Hose.
They're just hose that got old.
Look at that one.
I had a friend from [inaudible]
who was super macho, my friend.
You didn't show that on the screen.
Did you miss it?
You son of a bitch who has that?
Some, no, don't, don't. Poor Lady.
Grandma with ridiculous fake boobs.
My friend, uh, my friend, he was,
he was from Woodway, Super
Macho, and he was like, he had,
didn't have a lot of money and he had
like, he would, he was kind of a Gigolo.
He was having sex with this
woman who, she's old. She's
very well. I said, uh, I go,
what? She look like when she's naked.
It's a disaster. Does. I said, hey,
I can look to it when she go
to the bathroom. I have to
look, you know, over care.
Because yes, it has to be no light because
it's a disaster. Why is he doing that?
But he goes, he goes by, you know why
she looks at me? Oh Way. She's young.
She sees me. I come like
this, you know, young the ice,
ice,
make card.
I'll never forget this. I
was like, what? I'm Tofu.